Speaker 1: So we've been talking for a while
now. I mean, really since the January six riots
about the different stories that those who
want to excuse what happened on that day
have been telling about what took place. Many
of these stories you've heard before. It wasn't
really Trumpists. In other words, it was antifa in
disguise or people pretending to be Trumpists or
in direct conflict with that. It was Trumpists,
but they weren't violent. It was peaceful.
Obviously, those two can't both be true, but these
are examples of conflicting explanations for what
took place, or a few people did the wrong thing.
And it was less about politics, but more about
those people being unhinged or whatever. And they
should be punished, but not too too bad because
for political reasons, they're being held without
bail. And it's all too strict and the conditions
aren't good, and one guy didn't get vegan food
and so on and so forth. So there've been all these
different stories told the FBI. Set it up. Tucker
Carlson played with that one for a little while,
going to play a clip for you here, which
is kind of like the next iteration,
the next step in the evolution of this. And
this is a clip of Newsmax host Greg Kelly
suggesting that Democrats set up the riots and
maybe even carried them out. Maybe in some general
sense, Democrats set the conditions for the
riots, but maybe they actually just planned it.
They they did it, they did the whole thing. So
let's just go to this clip. I'm going to play a
couple minutes of it because even the lead up
is crazy. Again, this is on Newsmax. This is
really wacky, weaponized stuff. Let's get into it.
Speaker 3: I loved it. I love the trolley. I love
King Friday. He's going to show up
eventually. I loved it as a child,
as a four to seven year old child and occasionally
in college. Look, the land of make believe
is for children. It is not for adults, but we are
in Joe Biden's America. They want us to live in
the land of make believe they're going to pretend.
Speaker 1: Imagine smearing Mr. Rogers in order to
make this very ridiculous political point.
Speaker 3: Pretend that black children are
being killed by other black children. OK, now
Speaker 1: this is the black on black violence
myth. What do I mean? It's a myth. Are black
people killed by black people? Yeah. When
you look at the actual data, the odds of a
black person being killed by a black person
are within a couple percentage points of the odds
of a white person being killed by a white person.
We still have a relatively segregated country
and people overall are around people like them
and thus are likely to be victimized
by people that are like them.
For years, we've known this. They don't care.
Speaker 3: This is happening. This is happening,
and it can't be denied. This is a crisis. Yet
no one wants to talk about it. No one wants to
talk about this. It is happening and nothing
is being done. It has become so bad under
Joe Biden because, well, he's in so much denial.
How about this? The crime wave, the conventional
crime? I'm talking about robberies everywhere,
shootings and robberies. You know, Black Lives
Matter. The summer last year, it led to all kinds
of help yourself to anything you want to store.
Speaker 1: Consider how unhinged this is. By
the way, these are all unrelated issues that he
wants to put together, as Biden caused all of it.
Speaker 3: It's racist to make an arrest or even
call the cops. This is bad, bad stuff. So in
the land of make believe Joe Biden's land,
none of this stuff is happening. But what is
happening? The scourge of white supremacy? Yes,
white supremacy is responsible for all
this stuff. We had to go back quite some
way to find footage of this. White supremacy does
Speaker 1: exist now for people who are, you know,
he's making fun out of. We have to go back to
1925 to show a rally of white supremacists.
Of course, this whatever degree of of
problem you believe white supremacy is today
with the advent of the internet, social
media and other types of communication.
You don't need parades. Not everything that
lacks a parade doesn't exist, I think is the
point that we should be taking from this are
Speaker 3: some idiots who believe in that,
and they're off in the woods somewhere. Knock
yourselves out. Don't break the law. And if you
do well, you should be arrested.
Speaker 1: Here we go now.
Speaker 3: January six is another fixture in the
land of Make Believe that this was the worst thing
that ever happened. Not that it was a trespassing
event. Not that Democrats may have had a hand in
setting the conditions and even perhaps setting
the whole thing up. Whoa, there's something to
talk about there. All right. All this stuff is
going on. All the other stuff is not going on,
but they're saying it's going on. OK, so
Speaker 1: he just kind of goes into a completely
wacky, delusional stuff at this point
in time. So this is this is the next
iteration where they've tried to blame
everyone other than themselves. However.
When they blame Democrats for the insurrection.
They're admitting there was an insurrection,
right, like should we consider that a victory to
some degree? But this is another layer as to why,
as I've been saying earlier this week, these folks
have to be held accountable. And when I when I
say that, I mean, the insiders need to be voted
out of office in 2022. They're not going to be.
Many of the insiders are in dark red districts
and there's no chance that they're voted out. It's
just not going to happen. But we need there
to be consequences. Number one, in order to
be able to say, here are the people. It's not
Democrats. It's this list of people who rioted
and they've been found guilty and sentenced. And
it's this list of people in the House and Senate,
and they've lost their seats. We're not going to
get that. Not to the degree that I would hope,
but it's what we would need in order to undeniably
be able to push back against these horrible
narratives that are being created like maybe
Democrats not only set it set up the conditions,
but are actually set up the entire thing. There's
a contingent that won't care. There's a contingent
that will always believe it was antifa or it was
peaceful Trumpists or what. They're never going
to believe it. But we want to be chipping away
and having something really specific to say,
No, it wasn't Democrats. Not a single
Democratic member of Congress or whatever.
These were Trumpists. They were prosecuted. They
were found guilty. They were. They were sentenced.
These are the elected officials who did it, and
I wish I could say I was confident that we were
going to get that. I don't think that we are.
I still don't think that we are to the degree
that we really need it. If you think we're going
to get those consequences. Let me know when and
how you think we're going to get them, because
I don't think that mostly the slaps on the wrist
that we're seeing right now are cutting it and
we'll see. There are still many cases pending.